the senate battle over justice
ginsburg's vacant seat
is shaping up to be absolutely brutal
republican leaders say they're ready to
move forward with the confirmation by
election day democrats say voters should
decide who chooses the new justice
as nancy cordes reports the two parties
have reversed their opinions
from four years ago of course the
american people should have a say
in the court's direction this was what
republicans said in 2016.
there is a long tradition that you don't
do this in an election year
when then president obama nominated
merrick garland to replace the late
justice scalia nearly eight months
before the election
why would we deny the voters a chance to
weigh in on the makeup of the supreme
court
now with 43 days until this election
their argument has flipped
the president was elected to do this and
the senate was elected
to confirm this nomination republicans
say
they gained senate seats in 2018 which
amounts to an endorsement senate
majority is performing our
constitutional duty and fulfilling the
mandate that the voter
voters gave us it's not just republicans
who have a different take now
here's democratic leader chuck schumer
in 2016.
if republicans continue to stand in the
way and refuse to do their job
it will only be because they want donald
trump to pick the next
nominee speaking yesterday at ginsburg's
high school in brooklyn
schumer argued republicans should stick
to their 2016 position
especially since voting has already
begun in some states
try and decide this at this last time at
this late moment
is despicable and wrong and against
democracy
it's shoving the wishes of the hard
right
and the republicans who go along with
them down
america's throat republicans say there
will be a confirmation vote
this year let's be very clear if the
shoe
were on the other foot and the democrats
had the white house and the senate
they would right now be trying to
confirm another member of the supreme
court this weekend two republican
senators maine's susan collins and
alaska's lisa murkowski
urged their party to wait until after
the election
but it would take four republicans to
block a vote
and there's little democrats can do on
their own to slow things down
besides applying public pressure and to
mitch mcconnell
we need to tell him that he is playing
with fire
yesterday retiring republican senator
lamar alexander of tennessee said
he'd be willing to vote before the
election he too
had a different position back in 2016.
all eyes now are on two republicans mitt
romney of utah who has shown a
willingness to break with his party
before
and corey gardner of colorado who is
locked in a tough bid
for re-election some democrats argue
that if republicans push ahead with this
vote
then they should add seats to the
supreme court if democrats
win back control of the senate
democratic leaders haven't embraced that
idea yet
but they do say that all ideas are on
the table
gail a lot of ifs ands and buts there
thank you very much nancy